female supporters of deposed president
Mohamed Mursi using the four-fingered
symbol of the Muslim Brotherhood
movement to demand his release naughty
man is a member of the Muslim sisterhood
she accuses the military of having
staged a [ __ ] most of the people aren't
just here because of Mohammed Morsi that
gathered because people were noted
during the clearing of a bar square on
Orcas the 14th hundreds of people were
killed when security officers stormed a
brotherhood protest camp in Cairo zara
bar square but the population is divided
over what really happened that day many
Egyptians now openly despise the
Islamists civilians often attack Muslim
Brotherhood protests not Iman pays a
visit to what's called a family of
martyrs one of their sons Abdul Rahman
was shot dead about a month ago his
brother says he'd been peacefully
demonstrating for the Brotherhood when a
bullet hit him in the chest his father
says something needs to be done to stop
the cycle of violence each day we have
victims each morning we are reading
victims names in the newspapers tyll
tyll tyll what is the end of this what
you start blood and salt killing you
will not succeed in the end because it's
start now from fighting for therefore
for her principles and fighting for her
religion to revenge many Egyptians say
the Muslim Brotherhood is partly to
blame for the escalation in violence
some a eid used to belong to the
organization he accuses the Brotherhood
of authoritarianism and a lack of
transparency and though optically that
you have to commit all your time to the
mission giver and your mission is the
Brotherhood then you always have to ask
them for permission that flies in the
face of personal freedom which is
guaranteed under Sharia law inheritance
any alien militia
nati Munn and her fellow activists
refused to be intimidated they want the
military out and their civilian
president returned to office on mazine
confess don't we imagine that something
will change yes it's just a dream that
we have to do what we can meet me i'll
do i fax it goes on perfect but both
sides are refusing to budge since Mursi
was deposed the Muslim Brotherhood has
rejected negotiations with the military
reconciliation is more remote than ever